two things fill the mind with
ever-increasing wonder and all the more
often and more intensely the mind of
thought is drawn to them the starry
heavens above me and the moral law
within me pause for a second and let
that quote wash across your synapses
trying to find ways to reconcile
ourselves to our need for self
transcendence and our duty for moral
reasoning is at the epicenter of the
thinking minds existential angst
Immanuel Kant
possessed such a mind his ideas were so
progressive and so potent that he's
considered a very central figure in
modern philosophy he is the philosopher
that preceded Schopenhauer and Nietzsche
and produced an incredibly robust set of
doctrines and theories that allowed the
two to get inspired and formulate their
own ideas he's interested for
multifarious and his philosophical
repertoire included areas like
empiricism rationalism reason morality
metaphysics and aesthetics he was a very
curious mind that attempted to make
sense of the world around him in the
most plausible way people like Kant were
rare especially during the times when he
existed but when religion was a strong
and dogmatic societal force
enlightenment started to pose a threat
to morality and science was still at an
embryonic stage yet he considered an
intellectual and moral obligation to
occupy himself with the big questions of
the human condition from reason and
morality to metaphysics and aesthetics
the core of his belief system was the
fundamental idea of human autonomy how
to unshackle ourselves from our
delusions and imitations cultivate self
awareness and self ownership and
eventually allow humanity to move
forward with less distress and less
conflict it takes a lot of courage and
audacity to even scratched the surface
of such topics can not only scratch the
surface but he roaded it and when deeper
than almost anyone
Immanuel Kant was born April 22 17:24 in
königsberg Prussia today Konigsberg has
been renamed Kaliningrad and it's part
of Russia
his family was artisans of modest means
but never destitute as a child Kant was
sent to a deeply religious Lutheran
School where he was subjected to an
intense soul-searching regime that
included the study of the Bible prayer
immersion in religious practices and
reliance on divine grace he reacted
strongly against this dogmatic and
emotional approach to personal
development and this was portrayed
throughout his life via his extensive
promulgation of Reason and human
autonomy after school he attended
college at the University of königsberg
known as the Albertina his curriculum
encompassed various courses like
mathematics physics logic ethics and
natural law he was exposed to various
philosophers and scientists but his main
influences were both Leibniz Newton
Aristotle Locke and Hume following his
graduation he worked as a personal tutor
for children to make ends meet
and it wasn't until 7 in 54 at the age
of 30 that he started to lecture in
Albertina Kant represents the archetype
of the quintessential scholar he was an
avid reader and an avid writer his
devotion to his intellectual work was so
intense that he spent 16 years teaching
as an unsalaried lecturer and working
since 1766 as a sap librarian to
supplement his income throughout this
time he wrote numerous books and essays
on various topics but the year that
stigmatized his life was the year 1781
when he published his magnum opus the
critique of Pure Reason Kant spent many
years in isolation to finish this
groundbreaking work the book wasn't
really recognised upon its initial
publication it was dense difficult to
understand and full of contradictions
but Kant worked hard to improve his
image and in the upcoming years
published a series of books that
clarified his theories and established
him as one of the greatest philosophers
of all time
he died in königsberg on the 24 February
1804
the critique of pure reason is a
difficult book to read Kant uses
intimidating vocabulary in his attempt
to create concepts that haven't been
encountered before however it is one of
the most profound books I have ever read
first off let's start with the use of
the term pure this is very crucial
because Kant starts from a basis were
reason is stripped from every scientific
analysis and relies only on what is
presupposed by the human mind or a
priori knowledge as he calls it the
motivation behind his decision to delve
into this idea was the crisis of
enlightenment during his time reason was
the holy grail of enlightenment since it
motivated people to think for themselves
and also to criticize traditional
authorities like the church and the
state
but this paradigm shift engendered
different kinds of issues reason alone
is not a panacea helping people think
for themselves does not necessarily lead
to progress unaided reasoning encourages
fatalism materialism debauchery and even
authoritarianism even when it came to
morality enlightenment due to its
support of science could not entirely
justify free will
since it is jeopardized by the
mechanistic laws of nature we must be
free in order to choose what is right
over what is wrong because otherwise we
cannot be held responsible so this
mind-boggling conundrums that gave rise
to the intellectual crisis of
enlightenment let Kant to the inception
of the critique of Pure Reason during
can steam a very dominant philosophical
school of thought was empiricism
according to which knowledge derives
from sensory experience and
experimentation that is we're born we
have experiences we measure data and our
mind translates that experience and data
into knowledge in a nutshell the mind is
a tabula rasa or a blank slate one of
the main proponents of this idea was the
great Scottish philosopher David Hume
Hume based on empiricist ideals rejected
causality and embraced the idea of
constant conjunction by causality we
mean that every event must have a cause
hue
didn't like the necessity included in
that statement when a billiard ball hits
another billiard ball you hear a sound
and you see the motion of the two balls
there is a causal sequence but where in
that sequence did you perceive necessity
you didn't perceive it all you perceived
was succession of changes in the state
of the two balls
we saw one event and then another event
in conjunction Hume central argument was
that the future is not obligated to
mimic the past and that there is no
reason to believe in metaphysical
pre-existing knowledge Kant himself has
stated that by reading David Hume he was
awakened from his dogmatic slumbers
meaning that he gave him a different
perspective to look at the world however
the idea of constant conjunction
bothered Kant who after intense thinking
came up with a following revelation in
order to support the idea of constant
conjunction you need to presuppose the
existence of time and space so there
needs to be some pre-existing knowledge
there after all this is called cants
Copernican revolution in philosophy
four-count managed to achieve something
I came to what Copernicus achieved with
astronomy when he questioned the
assumption that the earth is the center
of the solar system and claimed that the
Sun is the center instead so Kant
postulated that some concepts like time
space or numbers are built in our
operational system so to speak our
brains are hard-wired to perceive time
and space without the need to understand
them he called this concept synthetic a
priori concepts the synthetic a priori
concepts form the basis for his
transcendental argument I call all
knowledge transcendentally which stills
not so much with objects as with our
manner of knowing objects insofar as
this manner is to be possible a priori a
system of such concepts would be called
transcendental philosophy synthetic a
priori concepts are concepts whose truth
is known independently of any experience
of the world he uses the term
transcendental because the knowledge we
have for these truths goes beyond our
empirical understanding of the world the
reason it was important for Kant to make
this statement was because he wanted to
emphasize the distinction
between the phenomenal world and the
noumenon world the phenomenal world is
the world as we experience it and
perceive it the nominal world is the
world as it really is independent of
anybody's experience it was imperative
for Kant to make that distinction for it
laid the groundwork for his ideas about
morality belief in God freedom and
immortality for Kant morality
constituted a central notion in the
human experience especially in an age
where most moral judgments originated
from religious dogmas Kant attempted to
find a way to somehow merge morality
with reason in his monumental work
groundwork of the metaphysics of morals
in order to do that he viewed morality
through the prism of what he called
categorical imperatives categorical
means absolute something unambiguously
explicit and direct imperative means
something crucial or of vital importance
kans terms might seem a bit
indecipherable at first but in that case
using a term with such gravity puts more
emphasis on the importance of how we
should view morality categorical
imperatives are our moral obligations
and can't believe that they derived from
Hue reason you don't need to have a
religion to tell you what is right and
what is wrong you can use your intellect
to figure that out by yourself so Kant
came up with different formulations of
the categorical imperative in order to
elucidate his stream of reasoning in his
first formulation he states act only
according to that Maxim whereby you can
at the same time will that it should
become a universal law before acting one
should ask oneself
what's the maxim of my action in other
words how do i act as if my behavior or
action can be universalized and how do I
add more clarity to the intent behind
everything that I do this is a great
thought experiment that can lead one to
the proper evaluation of his or her
actions before you do something morally
questionable ask yourself would I want
that act to be espoused by every soul on
this planet in his second formulation he
states act in such a way that you treat
humanity whether
your own person or in the person of any
other never merely as a means to an end
but always at the same time as an end
here he tries to raise awareness of how
the way we treat each other impacts our
understanding of morality and means to
an end
means a thing that is not valued or
important in itself but it is useful in
achieving an aim when you meet someone
and instead of identifying the humanity
in them you try to exploit them benefit
from them or just use them when you
treat them must means instead he
suggests that we should identify that
each human is a peculiar idiosyncratic
figure and we should treat them always
as ends in themselves in another
formulation he states act according to
Maxim's of a universally legislating
member of a merely possible kingdom of
ends here Kant discusses his vision for
the future of society's future
predicated on value and dignity as he
writes in the kingdom of ends everything
has either value or dignity whatever has
a value can be replaced by something
else which is equivalent whatever on the
other hand is above all value and
therefore admits of no equivalent has a
dignity the kingdom of ends is an
imaginary state whose laws protect
individual autonomy in this Kingdom
morality is not just a matter of how
individuals behave but it forms the
foundation of a healthy society of
course there will be people that will
view Khan's ideas as utopian unrealistic
or inapplicable on a global scale and
their right some people will always
succumb to their irrationality and be
victims to their own delusions
however attempting to understand Khan's
ideas is refreshing for the human mind
and they constitute a worth pursuing
step towards the redefinition of our
vision for Humanity right before his
last breath can't a third assist good
meaning it is good pity on Stein in a
similar fashion
a third tell them that I had a wonderful
life that is a similar pattern between
philosophers they dedicate their lives
to the search for meaning and in the end
they experience relief after their
journey finishes they try hard facing
harsh criticism occupying them
with topics so dear to the human
condition but also so challenging for
the human cognition it is a personal
responsibility for all of us not only to
respect their work but also to try to
understand them even to some degree just
for the sake of showing appreciation
just for the sake of injecting a little
bit more meaning to our lives hey guys
hope you enjoy today's video if you did
make sure to LIKE subscribe turn on
notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it if you want to
watch more videos from my channel check
out this one and this one take care see
you soon head here now